الروسي ليكون ايضا قريبا من المعارك لان
التصريحات والاتهامات التي يوجهها دائما
بريجوجين بانهم يجلسون في مكاتبهم ولا
يعلمون شيئا عن المعارك ويكون هو بشكل
مدافع عن المقاتلين هذه من ناحيه الناحيه
الاخرى بان العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
بالفعل تحرز تقدم في الاشهر الاخيره حيث
محور المثلث الناري ما بين كوبيانس كليمان
ما بين مقاطعات خاركيف دانياس كلوجان يعني
صباح اليوم باتت القوات الروسيه قريبه جدا
حسب تصريحات خبراء عسكريين
ومقاتلين على الارض من محور المعارك في
كوبيانس وفي ليمان وفي كريمنا ذلك المحور
الذي انسحبت منه القوات الروسيه في اواخر
العام الماضي هناك عوده للجيش الروسي
لاعاده السيطره على هذه المناطق ودفع
القوات الاوكرانيه للانسحاب منها مره اخرى
الحديث عن ثلاثه كيلومترات يعني تفصل
الجيش الروسي عن مدينه كوبيانس وفي ظل هذا
التقدم الكبير الذي اعتدت اليه رائد
في حكم المؤكد ان القوات الاوكرانيه
اتتحضر الان للانسحاب من بخود كما افادت
وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
يعني غالبا ان القوات الاوكرانيه ستنسحب
لكن هي تنتظر الامدادات العسكريه وتريد
تثبت الى الحليف الغربي او الى حلف الناتو
بانها قادره عن على قادره
قادره ان تدافع عن اراضيها حتى لو كان
عندها نقص في الذخيره بالفعل القوات
الاوكرانيه تعاني من نقص الذخيره وهذا ما
يعني يفسره انخفاض القصف الاوكراني على
المدن كانت القذائف تسقط بكثافه واليوم
هناك
طيران الروسي يحلق طبعا باستمرار منذ فتره
طويله دون توقف في هذه المنطقه الحديث
احمد ان النقص في الذخيره عند الجانب
الاوكراني يعني هو سبب كبير
لانسحاب القوات الاوكرانيه اذا تم ذلك